Tucker Carlson was reportedly fired by
Fox at least in part for the things he
said about Fox management as revealed in
the Dominion lawsuit so in some
incredible way Trump's hair brained
election lies which led to the attacks
on Dominion which led to the lawsuit led
to Tucker's firing in a sense Tucker's
firing came
from the big lie about the 2020 election
in terms of whether it's good for the
country to have Tucker off the air what
will likely be temporarily because
Tucker is going to find something else
of course Tucker broke the brains of
millions of people
he was seen by many on the right as a
real thinker which is hilarious and so
in some sense the country is better off
with Tucker not spouting propaganda on
the other hand he'll find some other
place to do it it just won't be Fox